« Émouvante » n'est peut-être pas l'adjectif qui vient en premier à l'esprit lorsqu'on lit cette lettre de Jacques, et pourtant, plus on la lit et plus on y réfléchit au parcours de son auteur, plus elle devient émouvante.
Il est émouvant en effet de lire cette lettre rédigée par un homme qui, avant de devenir le pasteur de l'église primitive à Jérusalem, avant d'être celui que l'apôtre Paul décrivait comme une colonne de l'église, fut d'abord pendant des années à la fois si proche et en même temps si loin de notre Seigneur Jésus-Christ, car Jacques était l'un des frères ou demi-frères de Jésus.
Ceux dont les évangélistes Jean et Marc nous disent qu'ils ne croyaient pas en Jésus, et qu'ils disaient même de leurs frères qu'il était hors de sens, ils disaient que Jésus était fou.
Mais lorsque Jésus-Christ leur apparut en Galilée, après sa résurrection, le Saint-Esprit toucha le cœur de Jacques, et il réalisa alors qu'il avait grandi pendant trois dizaines d'années aux côtés du Fils de Dieu,
sans croire à ce qu'il disait, en se moquant de ce qu'il faisait et en méprisant ce qu'il était.
Et nous voilà maintenant face à cette lettre rédigée par un homme au cœur si transformé, si rempli d'adoration, de dépendance et de consécration envers ce frère qui est devenu son Seigneur,
que l'historien chrétien Égésipe écrivit que Jacques priait tellement qu'il avait les genoux endurcis comme ceux d'un chameau.
Un homme au cœur autrefois dur et moqueur, dont les mots que nous avons sous nos yeux traduisent un cœur désormais rempli de tendresse, d'amour, de préoccupation, de soin et de zèle
pour la persévérance et les progrès spirituels de ceux qu'il appelle affectueusement ses frères bien-aimés dans la foi.
Cette lettre de Jacques qui est l'écrit le plus ancien du Nouveau Testament n'est pas la lettre de Paul aux Romains ou la lettre de très probablement Paul aux Hébreux.
Vous n'y trouverez pas de long développement de théologie systématique comme dans l'Épître aux Romains ou de théologie biblique comme dans l'Épître aux Hébreux.
C'est plutôt une suite d'exhortations à mener une vie chrétienne authentique, cohérente et impactante dans tous les domaines et en toutes circonstances.
C'est une lettre pastorale écrite par un pasteur à des chrétiens qu'il connaît, qu'il aime et dont il a déjà pris soin à Jérusalem,
mais qui ont dû fuir cette ville pour se disperser dans d'autres à cause de la persécution dont il souffre les terribles conséquences.
C'est ce cœur pastoral qui pousse Jacques, dès le chapitre 1, à leur adresser des mots qui, malgré ce que nous venons de rappeler de lui,
peuvent sembler durs à adresser à des personnes qui souffrent autant.
Mais c'est précisément parce que Jacques les aime et qu'il sait à quel risque ils sont particulièrement exposés au milieu des souffrances qu'ils endurent, qu'il leur parle ainsi.
Il sait que l'ennemi rôde et que dans des circonstances tragiques telles que celles-ci,
Satan peut semer dans le cœur de ses frères bien-aimés l'incrédulité, le ressentiment, l'angoisse, le découragement et même jusqu'à l'apostasie.
Et il n'y a rien de pire pour un chrétien qui aime un autre chrétien que de l'imaginer apostasier sa foi et échouer au seuil des portes du paradis,
après avoir si bien commencé et déjà tant souffert à cause de l'évangile.
C'est pour cela que Jacques les encourage vivement, virilement même pourrait-on dire, en leur disant par exemple, dès le chapitre 1,
regardez comme un sujet de joie complète ces diverses épreuves auxquelles vous êtes exposés.
Si vous manquez de sagesse, demandez-la à Dieu.
Ne doutez pas, ne soyez pas irrésolus, mais priez avec foi.
Supportez patiemment la tentation pour recevoir la couronne de vie.
N'accusez pas Dieu de vous tenter et de vous pousser à pécher.
Vous êtes les seuls responsables de votre convoitise et de votre désobéissance.
N'écoutez pas seulement, mais mettez en pratique la parole de Dieu.
Si vous pratiquez la vraie religion, tenez votre langue et visitez les veuves.
Et enfin, ne faites pas exception de personne.
Voici quelques exemples de ce que Jacques adresse dans les deux premiers chapitres de sa lettre à ces chrétiens qui ont fui la persécution.
Car ce qu'il veut leur éviter à tout prix, et par extension à nous aujourd'hui aussi,
c'est de croire aux murmures mensongers du diable qui insulvent dans leur esprit l'idée que ce qu'ils endurent justifie bien de faire quelques concessions dans leur foi.
Que ce soit des concessions doctrinales ou des concessions pratiques,
si cela peut leur permettre d'adoucir un peu l'intensité de leur souffrance et de leur éviter d'en subir de plus durs encore à l'avenir.
Car, frères et sœurs, Jacques sait que lorsque nous commençons à réfléchir ainsi,
à nous considérer comme victimes plutôt que coupables,
nous posons le pied sur une pente extrêmement glissante
qui peut progressivement nous mener au pire des compromis,
au pire négligence, au pire concession, au pire désobéissance,
et comme nous en avertit Jacques au verset 15 du chapitre 1,
même jusqu'à la mort de notre âme.
Lorsqu'un homme, notamment un chrétien,
commence à se définir plus comme une victime que comme un coupable gracié par Dieu,
il est alors prêt à justifier les plus terribles des péchés,
tout en se fermant totalement au message de l'Évangile,
ce qui est une combinaison fatale pour l'âme.
La seule voie pour nous chrétiens en tout temps,
dans les circonstances les plus favorables comme dans les moins favorables et les plus dures,
c'est de conserver, proclamer, transmettre et pratiquer notre foi
jusqu'à ce que notre Seigneur décide de nous rappeler à Lui.
Il n'y aurait rien de pire pour les dessinateurs de Jacques
et pour nous que de souffrir ces choses et d'échouer en nous arrêtant au milieu du chemin.
Nous devons tenir bon par la grâce de Dieu
et achever la course, mener le bon combat jusqu'au bout.
Et c'est ce but que Jacques vise à travers sa lettre
que nous, ses frères et sœurs en Christ, tenions ferme
et combattions le bon combat jusqu'au bout,
malgré les pièges de Satan, malgré l'opposition du monde
et tout cela pour la gloire de Dieu, notre Sauveur.
Voilà ce qui motive Jacques à adresser toutes ces exhortations
que nous avons déjà abordées jusqu'ici et rappelées à l'instant
et qui nous amènent ce matin aux versets 12 et 13.
Parlez et agissez comme devant être jugés par une loi de liberté
car le jugement est sans miséricorde pour qui n'a pas fait miséricorde.
La miséricorde triomphe du jugement.
Certains pourraient justement se dire que Jacques manque de cette miséricorde dans sa lettre.
Pourquoi adresser tant d'exhortations à l'obéissance, à la sainteté,
tant d'avertissements et même certains reproches
à des personnes qui ont dû quitter tout ce qu'elles avaient ?
Pour certaines ont perdu des êtres chers à cause de la persécution.
N'ont-elles pas déjà assez souffert, Jacques ?
N'ont-elles pas déjà assez prouvé leur fidélité à Christ ?
Leur obéissance à la volonté de Dieu ?
Ces personnes n'ont-elles pas simplement besoin d'entendre des mots réconfortants,
d'être consolés, rassurés, encouragés ?
Jacques ne manque-t-il pas justement de cette miséricorde
qu'il demande pourtant à ses frères et sœurs
de pratiquer les uns envers les autres dans ces deux versets ?
Rien n'est moins sûr, frères et sœurs.
Rappelez-vous qu'avant d'être ce pasteur pieux et aimant,
Jacques était assis sur le banc de ceux qui se moquaient de Jésus
et qui ne croyaient pas en lui.
Ne pensez-vous pas qu'après avoir ainsi méprisé son demi-frère pendant des années,
lorsque le Saint-Esprit lui révéla qui était véritablement Jésus-Christ,
lorsqu'il le vit de ses yeux ressuscité en Galilée,
glorieusement ressuscité, comme il le leur avait annoncé,
ne croyez-vous pas qu'il ne se lamenta pas
comme ses concitoyens juifs au jour de la Pentecôte ?
Hommes, frères, que ferons-nous ?
N'a-t-il pas très probablement ressenti dans son cœur
le même soulagement que l'apôtre Pierre,
lorsqu'il comprit que ce Jésus-Christ,
qu'il avait critiqué avec les autres et en qui il ne croyait pas,
ne lui imputait pas son péché,
mais l'avait au contraire porté et cloué pour lui sur la croix
afin qu'il en soit pour toujours pardonné ?
Ne sommes-nous pas face au mot d'un homme qui a expérimenté la miséricorde de Dieu
jusqu'au plus profond de ses entrailles ?
Il est impossible qu'un tel homme puisse ensuite manquer de miséricorde,
notamment envers ses frères et sœurs dans la foi qui souffrent de la persécution.
C'est au contraire un homme qui connaît désormais
la puissance et les effets bénéfiques de la miséricorde,
à la fois pour consoler et apaiser le cœur,
mais aussi pour consolider les liens au sein de l'Église
et pour glorifier le nom de Christ aux yeux du monde.
Car à ceci, tous connaîtront que vous êtes mes disciples
si vous avez de l'amour les uns pour les autres.
Et sans amour, pas de miséricorde.
Et sans miséricorde, pas d'amour.
Aimez vos ennemis.
Soyez miséricordieux comme votre Père est miséricordieux,
enseigne à notre Seigneur Jésus.
Nous sommes donc face à une exhortation bibliquement éprouvée
et réellement expérimentée par Jacques,
qui nous l'adresse avec amour et pour notre bien,
et nous devons donc y prêter la plus sérieuse des attentions.
Ces deux versets sont charnières dans le chapitre 2.
Il conclut les onze premiers que nous avons déjà étudiés
sur le péché d'acception de personnes ou favoritisme,
et ouvre la porte au trait suivant où Jacques abordera le lien
entre la foi et les œuvres.
Et puisque ces deux versets sont une conclusion,
pour bien les comprendre, nous devons nous rappeler rapidement
le développement dont ils sont le point final.
Des versets 1 à 7, Jacques nous rappelle que
favoriser certains hommes au détriment d'autres
sur la base de critères charnels, selon la chair,
est une négation pure et simple du caractère de Dieu,
de notre identité, de notre mission en tant que peuple de Dieu
et du message et des exigences de l'Évangile.
Si nous favorisons les riches parce qu'ils sont riches,
les beaux parce qu'ils sont beaux,
les intelligents parce qu'ils sont intelligents,
en occultant totalement l'état spirituel de leur cœur,
nous regardons à ce qui frappe les yeux et non au cœur,
nous agissons comme des enfants de Satan issus de l'AGN,
suivant les principes du monde,
et non comme des enfants de Dieu citoyen du ciel,
suivant les principes du royaume du Christ.
Nous nous rendons au Dieu à notre Père Céleste
en pratiquant le péché de favoritisme
ou d'acception de personne.
L'origine de ce péché dans l'histoire,
comme dans notre cœur humain, est satanique.
Et ce favoritisme est parfaitement incompatible
et incohérent avec la nature de Dieu,
qui se présente dans sa parole comme l'avocat
de la veuve et de l'orphelin,
qui lui-même ne fait pas exception de personne,
et qui nous appelle à refléter son caractère,
en traitant chaque homme avec la même dignité,
en cherchant son bien.
Ce que l'Église, comme nous l'a rappelé
notre pasteur Loïc tout à l'heure,
a historiquement fait tout au long des siècles,
en prenant soin des pauvres et des malades.
« Vous serez saints, car je suis saint,
dit l'Éternel. »
Puis des versets 8 à 11,
nous avons vu le contre-argument
que Jacques adresse à ceux qui chercheraient
à se défendre de leur péché de favoritisme
en faisant appel à la loi.
Grave erreur,
mauvaise stratégie,
car Jacques connaît très bien la loi,
comme nous allons encore le constater aujourd'hui.
Et il le répond, pour paraphraser,
quand bien même il serait vrai,
que vous obéissiez à tous les autres commandements,
car c'est une hypothèse ici,
mais que vous faites exception de personne.
Alors vous transressez la loi qui est à l'image de Dieu,
qui l'a promulguée, instaurée.
Une est indivisible,
et vous êtes donc condamné par cette loi.
La seule justice que cette loi reconnaît,
la seule obéissance que Dieu accepte,
c'est une justice et une obéissance parfaites,
sans aucun manquement,
sans aucun défaut.
Voulez-vous vraiment être jugé selon ce standard de justice ?
Voulez-vous vraiment qu'au jour du jugement dernier,
Dieu vous juge sur la base de cette loi une et indivisible ?
Pensez-vous pouvoir être à la hauteur des exigences divines de perfection morale ?
C'est la question qui vient naturellement suite à ces versets,
et que Jacques aurait même pu explicitement insérer entre les versets 11 et 12,
qui sont finalement la réponse à cette question.
Et c'est donc cette question que nous allons nous poser ce matin,
frères et sœurs, à la lumière des versets 12 et 13.
Selon quelle loi nous jugeons-nous les uns les autres ?
Et donc, serons-nous jugés par Dieu au jour du jugement dernier ?
Normalement, si vous êtes de bons protestants,
et que vous êtes concentrés sur la prédication,
vous avez dû relever une anomalie dans la question que je viens de poser.
Peut-être même deux.
Et si vous les avez manqués, les voici.
Comment ça, nous, chrétiens,
devons-nous être jugés par Dieu au jour du jugement dernier ?
Et comment ça, la façon dont nous jugeons notre prochain ici-bas,
conditionnera la façon dont Dieu nous jugera ce jour-là ?
Je crois qu'avec ces deux questions,
vous réalisez toute l'importance qu'il y a de comprendre
ce que Jacques nous écrit dans ces versets.
Car il ne nous dit ni plus ni moins, au verset 23,
que si nous ne faisons pas miséricorde,
Dieu nous jugera sans miséricorde.
Saisissez-vous tout le poids de cette affirmation ?
Serait-il possible que notre manière de vivre ici-bas
nous prive de la miséricorde de Dieu au jour du jugement dernier ?
Si c'est le cas, alors nous devons accorder la plus grande attention
à ce que Jacques nous enseigne ici
pour nous préserver de cette terrible issue.
C'est donc pour éclaircir ces sujets si importants
que nous allons répondre à cette question principale.
Selon quelle loi nous jugeons-nous les uns les autres
et donc serons-nous jugés par Dieu au jour du jugement dernier en trois temps ?
Premièrement, le jugement sans miséricorde.
Deuxièmement, le triomphe de la miséricorde.
Et troisièmement, faire miséricorde pour recevoir la miséricorde.
Parlez et agissez comme devant être jugés par une loi de liberté.
Notez tout d'abord qu'avec ces premiers mots au verset 12,
« parler et agissez »,
Jacques nous exhorte, comme à son habitude en réalité,
à inclure tout notre être dans ce qu'il va dire par la suite.
Rien de ce que nous faisons ou disons,
rien dans notre profession de foi ou dans la pratique de notre foi
ne peut se soustraire au principe qu'il va exposer dans la suite de ces deux versets.
Et comment donc nous, chrétiens, en tant qu'enfants de Dieu,
en tant que témoins et disciples du Christ devant le monde,
devons-nous donc parler et agir dans cette vie ici-bas
comme devant être jugés par une loi de liberté ?
J'en reviens donc à la question que je posais à l'instant.
Pourquoi Jacques laisse-t-il entendre que nous devons encore être jugés par Dieu ?
L'évangile ne proclame-t-il pas que Jésus-Christ a déjà été jugé à notre place sur la croix ?
Est-ce qu'un jugement nous attendrait encore,
nous, chrétiens, qui nous confions pourtant en Christ pour notre salut éternel ?
L'apôtre Paul ne dit-il pas dans sa lettre aux Romains
qu'il n'y a donc maintenant aucune condamnation
pour ceux qui sont en Jésus-Christ ?
Il n'est pas rare que les chrétiens se représentent
le jour du jugement dernier
comme une longue file d'attente de pécheurs
qui attendent d'être jugés et envoyés en enfer par Dieu,
file d'attente que eux, chrétiens, éviteront
en passant par un coupe-fil ou une entrée VIP vers le paradis.
En d'autres termes, beaucoup de chrétiens pensent
qu'ils ne passeront tout simplement pas
devant le tribunal de Dieu au jour du jugement dernier.
Mais ce n'est pas la description que la Bible fait de ce jour.
Dieu nous révèle dans sa parole que chaque être humain
sera convoqué et comparaîtra devant son tribunal
où Dieu siège comme juge de toutes ses créatures.
L'apôtre Paul écrit en effet dans sa lettre adressée
aux chrétiens de Rome
« Nous comparaîtrons tous devant le tribunal de Dieu »
et il écrit ici à une église, à des chrétiens.
Et de la même manière, dans son autre lettre aux Corinthiens
« Car il nous faut tous comparaître devant le tribunal de Christ ».
Jacques a donc raison de nous avertir
que nous devons nous préparer au jugement dernier.
« Car vous et moi, frères et sœurs,
ainsi que chaque être humain descendant d'Adam et Ève,
nous allons tous être convoqués
et nous allons tous comparaître devant le Dieu trois fois saint
lorsque la dernière trompette sonnera. »
Il n'y a pas de différence entre le croyant et le non-croyant
en ce qui concerne la convocation finale
à comparaitre devant le tribunal divin
dont le but commun lui aussi aux croyants et aux non-croyants
est de décider de notre destinée éternelle.
Et la similitude va plus loin.
Car si le croyant et le non-croyant seront convoqués,
c'est parce que l'un et l'autre, ne l'oublions pas,
restent des créatures de Dieu
qui se sont rendues coupables de rébellion,
de sédition contre leur créateur.
Il n'y a donc pas non plus de différence
sur la raison de cette convocation divine à comparaitre.
Il n'y a pas non plus de différence
sur le principe d'évaluation
de chaque être humain devant ce tribunal.
Les morts furent jugées selon leurs œuvres,
écrit l'apôtre Jean en Apocalypse 20.
Et l'apôtre Paul ajoute
« Car il nous faut tous comparaître devant le tribunal de Christ
afin que chacun reçoive,
selon le bien ou le mal qu'il aura fait. »
Toutes les pensées que nous aurons eues,
tous les mots que nous aurons prononcés,
tous les actes que nous aurons faits
ou négligés de faire,
seront évalués, pesés
et jugés par Dieu
selon ses standards de justice.
Nous serons tous jugés par Dieu
selon nos œuvres.
Et pour finir avec le point
qui nous concerne le plus ce matin,
il n'y a pas non plus de différence
sur la base que Dieu utilisera
pour évaluer nos œuvres à chacun.
Ce sera la loi.
Cette loi dont Jacques parle au verset 8 à 11,
cette loi une et indivisible
qui nous condamne justement
et impitoyablement.
la loi n'est rien d'autre
que l'expression législative
de la volonté de Dieu pour ses créatures.
Les dix commandements
qui constituent la loi morale
et qui est toujours en vigueur
pour nous aujourd'hui,
même pour le chrétien,
sont un résumé législatif
de ce que nous appelons la loi naturelle.
Et la loi naturelle
n'est rien d'autre que la volonté de Dieu
pour l'ensemble de sa création
et de ses créatures.
Tout ce que Dieu a créé était très bon.
Avant que le péché n'entre dans le monde
et ne corrompe cette harmonie parfaite,
absolument chaque atome
de chaque créature de Dieu
vivait conformément à la volonté parfaite de Dieu
pour le plus grand bien
et le plus grand bonheur
de cette créature
et de toute la création.
Et lorsque le péché est entré
dans la création
via le cœur de l'homme,
il a progressivement éloigné l'homme
de cette harmonie initiale
en le détournant de la volonté de Dieu,
donc de la loi naturelle
et donc, bien entendu,
de son propre bonheur.
Voilà pourquoi notre monde
est aujourd'hui si dysfonctionnel,
injuste, violent, triste
et désespéré.
Car l'homme qui en est le gouverneur
par décret divin
n'a de cesse d'éloigner ce monde
à sa suite de la volonté parfaite
et bonne de Dieu
pour sa création.
L'homme pêche contre Dieu
en transgressant la loi naturelle
parce qu'il est poussé par sa nature
qui est corrompue par le péché
à s'éloigner de la voie de son créateur
pour suivre ses propres voies
et pour rendre cette transgression
de la loi naturelle indiscutable
et légalement condamnable,
Dieu a rappelé au monde entier
à travers les dix commandements
qu'il a donnés à la nation d'Israël
sur le Mont-Sinai
la direction à suivre
pour se rapprocher de sa volonté
qui n'a pas changé
tout en rendant évident
notre incapacité à vouloir
et à pouvoir accomplir parfaitement
cette volonté.
La loi est juste et bonne
car elle n'est rien d'autre
que l'expression de la volonté de Dieu
et elle nous condamne aussi impitoyablement
car nous sommes désormais incapables
de l'accomplir
parce que notre cœur a été empoisonné,
corrompu jusqu'à la racine
par le péché transmis
de génération en génération
depuis Adam, notre père, à tous.
C'est bien de cette loi
dont Jacques parle des versets 8 à 11.
Celle dont, si nous entrons
réçons un seul des commandements,
nous condamne à l'enfer éternel
réservé à tous ceux
qui n'accomplissent pas parfaitement
chaque lettre de la loi naturelle
car cette loi est à l'image
de son législateur
parfaite, une et indivisible.
Je vous pose donc la question,
chers assemblés,
est-ce par cette loi-là
que vous souhaitez être jugé
par le Dieu trois fois saint
au jour du jugement dernier ?
Pensez-vous être à la hauteur
des standards de perfection de Dieu ?
Êtes-vous capable de vivre
sans jamais transgresser cette loi ?
Laissez-moi répondre à votre place
en vous disant qu'aucun de nous
n'en est et n'en sera jamais capable.
Il n'y a aucun espoir
pour celui qui voudrait forcer
les portes du paradis
en présentant à Dieu son obéissance
à la loi comme laissé-passer.
Alors si tous,
croyants et non-croyants,
seront convoqués,
comparaîtront,
seront jugés
pour la même raison,
dans le même but,
selon le même principe
et avec la même loi intransigeante,
où se situe donc la différence
entre ceux qui seront condamnés
à la mort éternelle en enfer
et ceux qui jouiront
de la vie éternelle au paradis.
Car la Bible affirme bien
ces deux seules issues possibles
suite au jugement final.
Et ceux-ci iront au châtiment éternel,
mais les justes à la vie éternelle.
Matthieu 25, verset 46.
En réalité, ce qui est vraiment étonnant,
c'est qu'il y ait ces deux issues possibles
au jugement dernier.
Car la Bible affirme aussi très clairement
que chaque être humain
naît pécheur,
privé de la gloire de Dieu,
qu'aucun ne fait le bien,
pas même un seul,
et que le salaire du péché
que nous commettons tous,
c'est précisément la mort éternelle
dans l'étang de feu,
qui est l'enfer.
Alors comment se fait-il
que malgré ces paramètres
qui ne nous laissent absolument
aucune chance d'être déclarés
juste par Dieu et devant lui,
certains obtiennent tout de même
la vie éternelle au paradis ?
Comment cela est-il possible ?
Et Jacques semble évoquer une solution
au verset 12
en mentionnant la loi de la liberté.
Y aurait-il finalement
une autre loi
par laquelle nous puissions être jugés ?
Une loi qui,
sans compromettre la sainteté
et la justice de Dieu,
ne nous condamnerait plus à l'enfer
et nous ouvrirait même
les portes du paradis.
Quelle merveilleuse nouvelle
ce serait, n'est-ce pas ?
Mais voici le problème.
Il n'y a pas d'autre loi
car il n'y a qu'un seul Dieu,
qu'un seul Créateur,
qu'une seule volonté divine
qui ne change pas,
qu'une seule loi naturelle
qui ne change pas non plus,
qu'un seul tribunal,
qu'un seul juge
et qu'un seul jugement.
Et l'unique volonté
de ce seul Dieu est immuable
et aucun iota de sa loi
ne passera jamais.
Comment donc
cette loi intransigeante
et immuable
qui nous condamne
impitoyablement
à la mort éternelle en enfer
pourrait-elle devenir pour nous
une loi de liberté ?
Comment cet instrument de mort
pourrait-il devenir
un instrument de vie ?
Comment cette loi
pourrait-elle proclamer
notre délivrance
et notre liberté
plutôt que notre emprisonnement
et notre esclavage ?
Jacques nous amène ici
dans l'impasse maudite
de notre condition humaine naturelle.
Comment résoudre
cet énigme insoluble ?
Il en va
de notre destinée éternelle,
frères et sœurs.
Nous avons vu
comment la loi
nous promet un jugement
sans miséricorde,
impitoyable.
Voyons maintenant
comment la miséricorde
a pu triompher
de ce jugement
impitoyable.
Car en effet,
la réponse
à cet énigme insoluble,
pour nous en tout cas,
Jacques nous la donne
au verset 13.
Gloire à Dieu,
mes frères et sœurs.
Car en Jésus-Christ,
notre glorieux sauveur,
la miséricorde de Dieu
a triomphé
de ce jugement
inévitable
et impitoyable
qui nous était réservé.
Non pas parce que Dieu
a tout d'un coup revu
à la baisse
ses exigences morales.
Non pas parce que Dieu
a finalement
abandonné sa justice.
Non pas parce que Dieu
a renoncé à nous châtier
de toute la force
de sa colère,
nous pécheurs.
non, mais parce que
notre grand Dieu,
dans son infini miséricorde,
a décidé d'envoyer
son Fils unique sur terre
afin qu'en étant
à la fois Dieu et homme,
il accomplisse parfaitement
à notre place
cette loi
qui nous condamnait.
La miséricorde,
c'est Dieu
qui voit notre misère
et notre péché
et qui intervient
pour nous secourir
en Christ
au lieu
de nous condamner
immédiatement
comme nous le méritons.
En effet,
Dieu a envoyé
son Fils
né d'une femme
né sous la loi
afin qu'il racheta
ceux qui étaient
sous la loi.
Nous,
c'est de nous
qu'il s'agit,
frères et sœurs,
afin que nous
ressuscions l'adoption.
Et Jésus a dit
je suis venu
non pour abolir
la loi
mais pour l'accomplir.
Et en accomplissant
parfaitement
cette loi immuable
dont nous venons
de parler,
cette loi une,
indivisible,
en l'accomplissant
devant Dieu
à notre place
jusqu'à sa mort
sacrificielle
sur la croix
et en nous unissant
à lui
par le moyen
de la foi,
Jésus-Christ
est devenu
notre justice.
Celui qui n'a point
connu le péché,
il l'a fait devenir
péché pour nous
afin que nous devenions
en lui,
Jésus-Christ,
justice
de Dieu.
lui qui n'est pas
venu abolir la loi
mais l'accomplir,
il est devenu
notre loi.
Non plus cette loi
qui nous sommes
d'être parfaits
devant Dieu,
mais la loi nouvelle
de l'Évangile
qui proclame
que nous sommes
une fois pour toutes
justifiés par Dieu
et devant Dieu
en Jésus-Christ seul.
Christ est la fin
de la loi
pour la justification
de tous ceux
qui croient.
l'Évangile est devenu
cette loi de liberté
par laquelle nous
serons jugés
par Dieu
et effectivement
il n'y a donc
maintenant
plus aucune
condamnation
pour ceux
qui sont
en Jésus-Christ.
Voilà ce qu'est
frères et sœurs
cette loi
de liberté.
C'est la même loi
que nous avons exposée,
la même loi
qui condamne tout homme
car il n'y a
qu'une loi
mais cette loi
ne nous condamne plus.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que Jésus-Christ
l'a accompli
à notre place.
C'est l'Évangile
qui proclame
la fin de notre
esclavage du péché,
de notre condamnation
à la mort éternelle,
de notre obligation
d'accomplir
la loi de Dieu
par nous-mêmes
car Jésus-Christ
est venu sur terre
l'accomplir
à notre place
allant jusqu'à
expier nos fautes
par son sacrifice
volontaire
sur la croix.
La loi de liberté
c'est l'Évangile.
dans lequel
la miséricorde,
la grâce
et la justice divine
triomphe
en la seule
et unique personne
de Jésus-Christ.
Lui,
le Messie,
a accompli
cette loi naturelle,
la volonté de Dieu
à notre place
et il nous a crédité
son obéissance parfaite
et a expié
toutes nos transgressions
et nous sommes
désormais
déclarés
justes
et progressivement
rendus justes
par la sanctification.
L'Évangile
est véritablement
en tout point
pour ceux que le Père
a unis au Fils
par le Saint-Esprit
une loi
de liberté.
Nous sommes
désormais
véritablement
libres,
frères et sœurs,
non pas libres
de faire ce que nous voulons
comme le monde
se figure la liberté
car c'est justement
cela le péché,
faire ce que l'on veut
sans tenir compte
de la volonté de Dieu.
Mais nous connaissons
désormais
la vraie liberté
qui se réalise
dans le brisement
des chaînes du péché
qui nous entravaient
si fortement
dans la redécouverte
du chemin
de la vraie liberté,
de la vraie joie
durable,
profonde
de la vie éternelle
dans une communion
que le Christ
a rétablie,
restaurée,
renouvelée
et même approfondie
pour nous
avec Dieu,
notre Père Céleste.
Voilà la vraie liberté
que notre Sauveur
et Seigneur Jésus-Christ
nous a acquises par sa vie,
sa mort
et sa résurrection sur terre.
Gloire à Dieu
car en lui,
la miséricorde
a définitivement triomphé
de notre jugement.
L'Évangile est donc bien
la seule loi
par laquelle
nous pouvons être déclarés
justes
et entrés
au paradis
au jour du jugement dernier.
C'est à la fois
la même loi impitoyable
et une nouvelle loi
de liberté
car l'enjeu
n'est plus de savoir
si nous pourrons
ou non
l'accomplir
par nous-mêmes
mais de savoir
si nous rejetons
ou embrassons
le seul
qui a pu
et qui a voulu
l'accomplir
à notre place,
le Dieu-homme
Jésus-Christ.
Et vous
qui m'écoutez ce matin,
avez-vous
embrassé
le Christ
ou lui crachez-vous
encore
au visage ?
Voilà où se trouve
la différence
entre ceux
qui seront jetés
en enfer
et ceux
qui seront accueillis
au paradis.
Les premiers
seront jugés
sur la base
de leur propre
obéissance
à la loi
car ils rejettent
le Christ
et les seconds
seront jugés
sur la base
de l'obéissance
du Christ
à la loi
car ils l'embrassent
par la foi.
Voilà la seule
variable
qui puisse
faire la différence
entre la malédiction
de l'enfer
et la bénédiction
du paradis.
Être représenté
par Christ
devant le tribunal
divin
au jour
du jugement
dernier.
Si vous êtes seul
face à la loi
ce jour-là,
vous mourrez
éternellement
comme vous êtes
déjà mort
en vous-même.
Si vous avez
Christ
comme avocat
à vos côtés,
vous vivrez
par ses œuvres
comme vous vivez
déjà éternellement
en lui.
Nous,
chrétiens,
aurions dû être
condamnés
comme les autres
sur la base
de la même loi
et selon le même
principe des œuvres.
La seule différence
réside dans le fait
que devant le tribunal
de Dieu,
nous ne présenterons
pas nos œuvres
mais celles
de Christ
qu'il est venu
accomplir
à notre place.
L'évangile,
c'est la bonne nouvelle
du triomphe
de la miséricorde
sur le jugement
car Christ a satisfait
la justice de Dieu
en accomplissant la loi
et que cet accomplissement
devient le nôtre
par le moyen
de la foi.
Nous ne sommes plus
transgresseurs
et morts en Adam
mais justes
et vivants
en Jésus-Christ.
Qu'en est-il pour vous
ce matin ?
Parlez-vous
et agissez-vous
dans votre vie
comme devant être jugés
par cette loi
de liberté,
par cet évangile
de la grâce
et de la miséricorde.
si la miséricorde
de Dieu
a triomphé
du jugement
qui vous était
réservé,
est-ce que
votre miséricorde
triomphe
du jugement
que vous réservez
à votre frère ?
Avez-vous
expérimenté
comme Jacques
au plus profond
de vous
cette miséricorde
qui vous pousse
à votre tour
à faire
miséricorde ?
Faites-vous
miséricorde
à votre frère
comme Dieu
vous a fait
miséricorde ?
C'est le moyen
que Jacques nous donne
au verset 13
pour savoir
si nous avons reçu
cette miséricorde
et cela nous amène
à notre troisième point
le plus controversé
on va dire
dans sa formulation
faisons miséricorde
pour recevoir
miséricorde.
C'est un langage
qui nous met
tout de suite
sur la défensive
car nous avons raison
en tant que protestants
de protéger
avec vigilance
les doctrines
du salut
par la grâce
et de la justification
en Christ
seul
par le moyen
de la foi
et comme nous venons
de le voir
mis à part
notre péché
qui a rendu
nécessaire
notre salut
nous n'avons contribué
en rien
à notre salut
c'est Dieu seul
qui a décidé
de l'accomplir
de A à Z
nous n'avons
généralement aucun problème
à ce qu'on nous dise
Dieu vous a fait
miséricorde
donc faites
et c'est en somme
l'exhortation
que nous venons
de contempler
au verset 12
mais lorsque nous entendons
comme notre Seigneur
Jésus lui-même
nous enseigne pourtant
à prier
pardonne-nous
nos offenses
éternelles
comme nous pardonnons
nous aussi
à ceux
qui nous ont offensés
ou alors
encore plus explicite
pardonnez
afin que votre Père
vous pardonne aussi
il nous semble alors
que le pardon
que Dieu nous accordera
dépend du pardon
que nous aurons
ou non accordé
aux autres
que si nous ne pardonnons
pas
Dieu ne nous pardonnera
pas non plus
mais si la Bible
n'a aucun problème
avec ce langage
et ses versets
montrent que c'est le cas
et que nous
oui
alors le problème
ne se trouve pas
dans la Bible
dont l'auteur est Dieu
mais bien chez nous
en fait
ce langage
pointe vers un mouvement
biblique récurrent
qui est un cercle vertueux
Dieu nous a fait
miséricorde
pour que nous puissions
faire miséricorde
à notre prochain
donc Dieu fera preuve
de miséricorde
au jour du jugement
dernier
de manière plus générale
car c'est un cercle vertueux
qui ne concerne pas
que la miséricorde
mais toutes les vertus
que Dieu nous appelle
à développer
dans notre vie
Dieu nous sauve
pour nous transformer
pour que nous entrions
au paradis
pour le moment
la formulation
est encore polémique
mais nous allons
éclaircir
tout cela
certains
qui ne comprennent pas
ce langage
biblique
réinterprètent
ou rejettent
même
ces versets
qui donnent l'impression
si nous les lisons mal
que ce que nous faisons
détermine
ce que Dieu fera
de nous
que ce sont
notre obéissance
et notre justice
qui déterminent
si nous passerons
l'éternité
au paradis
ou en enfer
et les protestants
sont les premiers
à être au mieux méfiants
et au pire hostiles
à ces versets
Luther lui-même
a pu avoir
des mots très durs
contre cet épître
de Jacques
et en grande partie
pour cette raison
et nous sommes face
à un de ces versets
ici
puisque Jacques
affirme
que nous serons jugés
sans miséricorde
si nous n'avons pas fait
miséricorde
dans notre vie
ici-bas
et c'est vraiment
un point
très important
à comprendre
frères et sœurs
car ceux qui cherchent
même avec de bonnes motivations
à réinterpréter
ces versets
parce qu'ils ont peur
qu'ils contredisent
la justification
au Christ seul
par le seul moyen
de la foi
finissent par atterrir
encore plus loin
de la vérité
des écritures
et à contredire
même d'autres doctrines
avec toutes les conséquences
que cela a
pour leur foi
et pour celles
de ceux
qu'ils enseignent
ou conseillent
la clé
pour comprendre
ces versets
se trouve
dans le lien
parfaitement
insécable
qui unit
tous les aspects
de notre salut
entre eux
et notamment
notre justification
et notre sanctification
un lien
que notre pasteur David
nous a patiemment
exposé
dans sa série
de prédications
sur l'épître
au Galate
lorsque Dieu
nous fait don
de la foi
il nous unit
au Christ
et nous recevons
en nous
le Saint-Esprit
qui nous sanctifie
progressivement
en nous restaurant
à l'image du Christ
qui est lui-même
l'image de Dieu
en un instant
par la seule
volonté de Dieu
comme l'écrit
l'apôtre Paul
nous sommes
appelés
justifiés
et même
déjà glorifiés
nous recevons
par la grâce
de Dieu
toute la plénitude
du Christ
et de ses bienfaits
qui nous a acquis
par son obéissance
parfaite
son sacrifice
sans défaut
sa résurrection
miraculeuse
et son intronisation
glorieuse
à la droite du Père
tout cela est vrai
pour chacun
d'entre vous
qui a contemplé
le Christ
dans l'évangile
à plier
le genou
dans la confession
et la repentance
de ses péchés
et que la main
gracieuse
et miséricordieuse
de Christ
a relevé
et chacun
peut constater
la réalité
de cette nouvelle naissance
de cette restauration
spirituelle
par l'habitation
du Saint-Esprit
qui est rendue
visible
et manifeste
en chaque chrétien
par la croissance
du fruit de l'Esprit
dans tous les domaines
de notre vie
pour le dire
beaucoup plus
courtement
nous ne pouvons
absolument pas
séparer
notre justification
de notre sanctification
celui qui est
justifié par Christ
devant la loi
sera sanctifié
à l'image du Christ
en obéissant
à la loi
tant et si bien
que celui qui n'est
de manière évidente
pas sanctifié
à l'image du Christ
n'est pas non plus
justifié
par le Christ
et attention
car c'est là
le point le plus
important
pour comprendre
le verset 13
selon ce principe
doctrinal
bibliquement
indiscutable
que nous venons
d'exposer
affirmer
que seuls
ceux qui ont
reçu
miséricorde
de la part
de Dieu
entreront
au paradis
et seuls
ceux qui font
miséricorde
à leur prochain
entreront
au paradis
est correct
et est vrai
en réalité
cela est une seule
et même affirmation
car la source
de notre justification
et de notre sanctification
est la même
c'est le Christ
auquel nous sommes
unis
et aucun de nous
ne reçoit
une moitié
de Christ
mais la plénitude
du Christ
avec tous ses bienfaits
et tous ses effets
dans tout notre être
si ceux qui entreront
au paradis
sont seulement
ceux qui sont
unis au Christ
et que ceux
qui sont unis au Christ
pratiquent la justice
alors seulement
ceux qui pratiquent
la justice
entreront au paradis
affirmer que
seuls
ceux qui sont
justifiés par Christ
entreront au paradis
et que seuls
ceux qui obéissent
à la loi de Dieu
entreront au paradis
sont deux façons
de désigner
la même réalité
d'un chrétien authentique
cela devient faux
si on l'affirme
en dehors de Christ
évidemment
mais
tant que le Christ
reste la source
de tous les bienfaits
de notre salut
alors cette déclaration
est vraie
voilà pourquoi
Jacques peut affirmer
que le jugement
est sans miséricorde
pour qui n'a pas fait
miséricorde
car celui
qui n'a pas fait
miséricorde
à son prochain
montre
qu'il n'a tout simplement
pas expérimenté
la miséricorde
de Dieu
envers lui
ce qui veut dire
qu'il n'est pas
unis au Christ
et qu'il ne sera
donc pas jugé
par la loi de la liberté
mais la loi
qui le condamne encore
voilà comment
vous devez comprendre
ce type de verset
qui ne représente
plus aucune tension
avec la justification
par le seul moyen
de la foi
en Christ seul
lorsqu'ils sont
ainsi interprétés
lorsque vous comprenez
que le fruit
de l'esprit
dans votre vie
est à la fois
absolument inséparable
de votre justification
en Christ
et qu'il est aussi
la preuve
que vous bénéficiez
personnellement
de cette justification
objectivement accomplie
par Christ
dans l'histoire
alors même
les versets
qui affirment
que sans la sanctification
personne ne verra
le Seigneur
ou même
que ce sont
ceux qui font
la volonté du Père
qui entreront
dans le royaume
des cieux
ces versets
ne représentent plus
aucune incohérence
doctrinale
ou difficulté
pratique
voici comment
nous pouvons résumer
cette vérité
seuls ceux
qui sont unis
au Christ
entreront
au paradis
or
ceux qui sont
unis au Christ
pratiquent la justice
ou portent
du fruit
de l'esprit
donc
seulement ceux
qui pratiquent
la justice
entreront
au paradis
maintenant
dites moi
si vous voyez
une personne
qui ne fait pas
miséricorde
à son prochain
dont la vie
est caractérisée
par le manque
de miséricorde
envers son prochain
quelle sera
votre conclusion
oh mais non
attention
il faut bien
distinguer
la justification
de la sanctification
la foi
des oeuvres
l'évangile
de la loi
attention
ce n'est pas
parce que ce pommier
donne des figues
que ce n'est pas
un pommier
non
vous allez dire
voici quelqu'un
qui n'a pas
expérimenté
la miséricorde
de Dieu
à travers
l'évangile
voici quelqu'un
qui ne s'est jamais
contemplé
dans toute sa laideur
dans toute sa misère
et toute sa perdition
spirituelle
face à la splendeur
immaculée
de Dieu
trois fois saint
et qui n'a jamais
contemplé
la face aimante
du Christ
s'approcher de lui
pour lui dire
mon frère
relève-toi
tes péchés
sont tous effacés
ta dette
est entièrement payée
et ton manteau
est désormais
immaculé
entre dans la présence
de Dieu ton père
et célèbre avec moi
les noces
de l'agneau
frères et sœurs
un homme
une femme
un enfant
à qui le Saint-Esprit
accordait
une telle
entrevue royale
avec le fils
de Dieu
à qui Dieu
a révélé
toute l'étendue
de sa miséricorde
envers
les pécheurs
rebelles
que nous étions
ne peut manquer
de faire preuve
à son tour
de miséricorde
envers son prochain
et encore plus
de miséricorde
envers son frère
ou sa sœur
en Christ
qui a connu
la même miséricorde
de la part
du même Dieu
et si Dieu
n'a pas refusé
de faire miséricorde
à de tels pécheurs
de tels rebelles
de tels idolâtres
que nous étions
qui l'ont tant offensé
comment pourrions-nous
refuser
nous qui avons
l'Esprit Saint
qui nous donne
la volonté
et la force
d'obéir
à la volonté
de notre Père
miséricordieux
comment pourrions-nous
refuser
de faire miséricorde
les uns aux autres
afin de couvrir
à notre tour
à l'image
de notre Dieu
une multitude
de péchés
nous l'avons vu
la miséricorde
triomphe du jugement
seulement pour ceux
qui sont en Christ
si donc votre absence
de miséricorde
prouve que vous n'êtes
pas en Christ
alors votre jugement
sera celui
que Dieu réserve
à tous ceux
qui ne sont pas en Christ
un jugement
sans miséricorde
le jugement
est en effet
sans miséricorde
pour celui
qui ne fait pas
miséricorde
car celui
qui ne fait pas
miséricorde
montre
qu'il n'est pas
uni au Christ
qui est le seul
à transformer
la loi
impitoyable
en loi de liberté
pour ceux
qui se confient en lui
Jacques
vous encourage
à montrer
à montrer que la miséricorde
de Dieu
a réellement triomphe
de votre jugement
en Jésus Christ
en faisant miséricorde
à votre tour
car si vous ne faites pas
miséricorde
vous prouvez aux yeux
de tous
que vous êtes toujours
condamné par la loi
impitoyable
et non délivré
par la loi
de la liberté
que vous êtes toujours
esclave de votre chair
et non libre
par l'esprit de Dieu
que vous vivez
toujours selon les principes
de la loi naturelle
qui vous condamne
impitoyablement
comme transgresseur
et non sous la loi
de l'évangile
dans laquelle
la miséricorde
triomphe du jugement
oui
seuls ceux
qui font la volonté
du Père
entreront
au paradis
non
pas parce que
leurs bonnes oeuvres
méritent le paradis
loin de là
mais parce qu'en ayant
obéi à la volonté
du Père
ils ont rendu
manifeste
qu'ils étaient
de nouvelles créatures
le temple du Saint-Esprit
uni au Christ
qui leur ouvrira
lui-même en grand
les portes du paradis
en leur disant
c'est bien
bon
et fidèle serviteur
tu as été fidèle
en peu de choses
je te confierai beaucoup
entre
dans la joie
de ton maître
et permettez-moi
de trouver ces versets
tout à fait pertinents
pour la semaine
de conférence
qui nous attend
la providence
permet que nous soyons face
à cette exhortation
précisément
aujourd'hui
et nous savons
combien cette conférence
annuelle
avec la fatigue
les imprévus
les différences
de caractère
et les nombreuses
sollicitations
peut représenter
un défi
pour nos relations
fraternelles
pour le témoignage
que nous nous rendons
les uns aux autres
ainsi qu'aux frères
et sœurs
d'autres églises
et même aux non-chrétiens
qui pourraient être présents
et donc je nous exhorte
chers assemblés
à garder
ces versets en tête
tout au long
de la semaine
qui vient
et au-delà
bien entendu
la miséricorde
triomphe du jugement
apprenons à couvrir
nos péchés
en nous faisant
miséricorde
les uns aux autres
tout comme Dieu
a couvert les nôtres
en nous faisant
miséricorde
lorsqu'un frère
ne nous accordera pas
l'attention
que nous aurions voulu
lorsqu'une sœur
nous parlera
avec moins de douceur
que d'habitude
lorsqu'une demande
de dernière minute
nous privera
d'écouter l'enseignement
comme nous l'avions
souhaité
lorsqu'un manque
de communication
ou d'organisation
viendra troubler
notre journée
faisons preuve
de miséricorde
les uns envers
les autres
rappelons-nous
dans ces moments-là
et pas seulement
la semaine prochaine
mais dans toutes celles
qui suivront
la quantité
et la gravité
de nos offenses
dont la miséricorde
de Dieu
a glorieusement
triomphé
en Jésus Christ
et que cela nous permette
avec l'aide du Saint-Esprit
de prendre du recul
sur les offenses
qui pourraient
nous être faites
et d'en triompher
à notre tour
en faisant miséricorde
à notre prochain
c'est précisément
pour que nous ayons
la volonté
et la force
de le glorifier
et d'être ses témoins
en nous faisant miséricorde
les uns aux autres
que le Père
et le Fils
nous ont envoyé
l'Esprit Saint
pour vivre en nous
si nous sommes cachés
en Christ
et que le Christ
vit en nous
alors comment
sa miséricorde
ne pourra-t-elle pas
progressivement
imprégner notre être
entier
et s'exprimer
dans notre vie
afin que nous parlions
et agissons
comme devant être jugés
par l'Évangile
cette loi de liberté
par laquelle
la miséricorde de Dieu
triomphe
de notre jugement
n'est-ce pas émouvant
lorsque nous voyons
concrètement
la miséricorde
en action
au milieu de nous
lorsque l'amour
couvre véritablement
une multitude
de péchés
et c'est alors
que le monde
qui peine déjà
à maintenir l'unité
dans les groupes
les plus homogènes
nous regarde
nous l'Église
et se demande
comment autant
de personnes
aussi différentes
peuvent-elles être
en même temps
si semblables
si proches
et autant persévérer
dans l'amour
qu'ils décident
d'avoir les uns
pour les autres
la réponse
tient en un seul nom
le plus glorieux
de tous
Jésus-Christ
alors frères et sœurs
je vous pose la question
selon quelle loi
jugez-vous
votre prochain
aujourd'hui
et notamment
votre frère
dans la foi
la loi impitoyable
ou la loi
de la liberté
qu'est-ce que cela dit
de l'état spirituel
de votre cœur
avez-vous expérimenté
la miséricorde
de Dieu
ou bien êtes-vous
toujours condamné
par la loi
la miséricorde
de Dieu
a-t-elle triomphé
de l'orgueil
et de la dureté
de votre cœur
ou bien êtes-vous
encore intransigeant
avec votre prochain
parce que vous êtes
encore esclave
de la puissance
du péché
face à tout cela
selon quelle loi
pensez-vous
que vous serez jugé
par Dieu
au jour du jugement
dernier
vous présenterez-vous
seul
avec votre propre
justice
face à la loi
devant Dieu
ou tiendrez-vous
la main percée
du Christ
qui défendra
votre cause
devant tous
c'est par la loi
de l'évangile
que nous serons
tous jugés
avez-vous
embrassé
le Christ
j'aimerais conclure
par la lecture
du commentaire
que Matthew Henry
fait de ces versets
commentaire qui synthétise
très bien
ce que nous venons
de contempler ensemble
l'évangile
est appelé
une loi
il possède
toutes les caractéristiques
d'une loi
des commandements
accompagnés
de récompenses
et de châtiments
il prescrit
des devoirs
aussi bien
qu'il dispense
du réconfort
et Christ
est un roi
pour nous gouverner
tout autant
qu'un prophète
pour nous instruire
et un prêtre
pour offrir
le sacrifice
et intercéder
pour nous
nous sommes
sous la loi
du Christ
c'est une loi
de liberté
et nous n'avons
aucune raison
de nous en plaindre
comme d'un joug
ou d'un fardeau
car le service
de Dieu
selon l'évangile
est une parfaite
liberté
il nous affranchit
de toute dépendance
servile
soit à l'égard
des hommes
des choses
de ce monde
nous serons tous
jugés
par cette loi
de liberté
la condition éternelle
des hommes
sera déterminée
selon l'évangile
c'est le livre
qui sera
grand ouvert
lorsque nous
comparaitrons
devant le tribunal
du jugement
il n'y aura
aucun secours
pour ceux
que l'évangile
condamne
et aucune accusation
ne pourra être retenue
contre ceux
que l'évangile
justifie
il nous importe
donc
de parler
et d'agir
dès maintenant
comme il convient
à ceux
qui doivent bientôt
être jugés
par cette loi
de liberté
c'est à dire
de nous conformer
aux exigences
de l'évangile
d'avoir une conscience
des devoirs
qu'il prescrit
d'avoir un esprit
conforme
à l'évangile
et que notre conduite
soit une conduite
conforme à l'évangile
puisque c'est selon
cette règle
que nous serons jugés
Amen